in some ways the Federal Reserve is like
a company it has a balance sheet with
assets that bring in money on one side
and liabilities that cost money on the
other but what the FED keeps on its
balance sheet has ramifications for the
economy the balance sheet is the tool
that they use to control and manage
interest rates and for the last 15 or so
years the Federal Reserve has actually
made money off of this balance sheet
until today thanks to well the fed's own
policies they're losing money because
they're raising interest rates a lot
here's how the FED makes money and why
they're not now
this is what their balance sheet looks
like on the asset side they have U.S
treasury Securities like bonds they're
considered really stable low-risk
Investments and the FED buys them
sometimes a lot of them to help
stabilize the economy the point of it is
to bring down longer-term interest rates
so if more people are purchasing these
Securities in this case the fed that's
going to drive down the interest rate
there's more demand for the bond and the
FED purchases mortgage-backed Securities
too which are what they sound like when
they invest in them they're basically
investing in people's mortgages if you
have a two and a half percent mortgage
rate that was in part because the Fed
was buying mortgage-backed Securities
during the pandemic so that's the asset
site which totals nearly nine trillion
dollars on the liability side the
Federal Reserve has literally all of the
currency in circulation it's why all
money has Federal Reserve note written
on it it's a liability of the fed the
U.S Central Bank the FED is also a bank
for other Banks and their main liability
is reserves of money that other Banks
keep at the FED it's another way they
can influence the economy there's some
concern that if you had all this money
out there you could have even more
inflation you could have economic
effects that you don't intend so one of
the ways to prevent that money from
spurring even more demand is to have
Banks hold it at the fed and the FED
controls interest rates by setting the
rate of interest on those Reserves
when the FED raises interest rates on
these reserves it affects other markets
from bank loans to mortgages but really
it means the Federal Reserve has to pay
more in interest to those Banks
for years that amount was really low
usually below one percent
yet the fed's assets on average pay 2.3
percent in interest
so the fed's assets were bringing in
more interest than its liabilities were
costing the Fed was actually turning a
profit and it would send that profit to
the U.S treasury
in the last 11 years this profit would
range from about 4 to 12 billion dollars
a month the money that the FED sends to
the treasury means the treasury doesn't
have to raise as much money in the
private Market it means the borrowing
needs of the US government are smaller
it means deficits are lower than they
would otherwise be but now that the
Federal Reserve is Raising interest
rates that profit is now a loss they are
raising interest rates so much that
they're going to pay more out than they
take in
this idea of the FED even having a
profit or loss is a relatively new one
before 2008 the fed's balance sheet
looked like this about a trillion
dollars in assets and liabilities mainly
treasury Securities to cover the
currency in circulation
but then the 2008 financial crisis hit
they dropped interest rates to zero but
wanted to do even more so they bought
Treasury and mortgage-backed securities
to push interest rates down even further
that began a decade of growth of the
fed's balance sheet as interest rates
stayed low and the Central Bank utilized
these assets and liabilities to
influence the economy although they
tried to shrink the balance sheet at
times the plan was never to permanently
expand the balance sheet then covet
comes and there was a financial panic in
March 2020 and they bought just an
enormous staggering amount of Treasury
Securities and mortgage-backed
securities so with a large balance sheet
comes large profits but now also large
losses so when the FED loses money what
happens they create basically an IOU
where they will pay back later the money
that they're losing now they call this a
deferred asset basically they'll pay
themselves back later the treasury will
have less money which means they'll have
to take on more debt to add to the
deficit but for the Federal Reserve
experts say it shouldn't change their
day-to-day operations and they're not
too worried about it the fed's pretty
clear their goals are to achieve low and
stable inflation and strong employment
it doesn't say anything anywhere that
they're supposed to make a lot of money
for the US government and so that's how
they're treating this right now now that
the FED has accumulated such a large
balance sheet to manage the economy it
must manage not just its gains but also
its losses
foreign